[Applaudissements]
comédie musicale as tu choisi l'an
vivait lui l'envié mais on va commencer
donc par céline donc mozart l'opéra rock
c'est ça céline ses dix commandements
alors tu y vas tu chantes bien tu
chantes fort et je te couperai lieu de
20 secondes tu es prête c'est toi qui
juge alex sociaux top c'est parti je
finis à la teinte en phonie requiem
quillan pas l'impression que quand tu
chantes tu as gros tuyau en face de toi
qu'elle a à offrir
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien ces lieux où est ce que
j'apprécie dans la performance de céline
elle a cherché le risque la chercher au
mon père s'est caché était notre
candidat dont j'ai oublié le prénom je
l'avoué humblement nicolas meyer le ton
dans l'oreillette nicolas qu'est ce que
tu as choisis tu m'as dix commandements
il aurait cru qu elle est à dire des
mails envie de des mères n'est d'accord
un joli succès le week-end mais qu'elles
me tour attention ces contrats dont la
fiche de pavant et bâle a bien assuré
à toi de jouer vous êtes apte à porter
pour trouver les voies non chez ferme en
l'amour
tellement poussé l'amour hacker l'auto
regarde tour à qui le veut vraiment est
en toi c'est toi le ctc sur le chemin
vas-y la halle et mai dernier nous on
veut ce sera demain leur offrir deux
phrases nous dès demain c'est bien ce
qu'on pensait je plaisante
et c'est difficile non non non non allez
alex mais bien sûr elle t'embrasse aussi
là les doigts tu viens de la voir en
nuisette et tout le monde adore non je
dirais qu'il n'ya qu'une céline à las
vegas donc c'est nico qu'à gagner ni
quand tu veux gagner le 15
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]